going back to Thailand
um okay
I don't know I don't I don't know if
this is just people that I've uh I've
had around me but there's one thing I've
realized growing up and talking to more
of my Asian friends I don't and I want
to confirm if this is a thing that's
widespread or this is a me thing I don't
know I got you okay I can ask you this
okay
does every Asian family have the
spiciest [__] Asian drama like the
spiciest family drama just hidden away
somewhere
oh is this just or is this just
something I've just noticed as I've like
grown older about the people around my
friends and my Asian family I don't I
don't think it has to do with an Asian
family I think it just has to do with
big families right because the more
people get involved Yeah the more likely
you're gonna run into someone not liking
someone yeah right because my Asian
family is quite small right like
comparatively to other Asians yeah yeah
yeah and as far as I'm concerned like
yeah I don't really know of any like
drama that's happened in the family yeah
I've because I've noticed this because
I've um you know uh because growing up
right growing up
um especially you know especially in a
lot of Southeast Asian families I've
seen you grow up and you you grew up
with a lot of the same like family
values treasure family love your family
and like there's there's a big thing you
know in Thailand where you call everyone
you know Auntie or uncle or cousin or
brother you know you call your you call
your cousin's brother sister and
sometimes you call all family friends
brother and sister and then you call
your Auntie and Uncle Auntie Uncle and
then you call your family's friends
Auntie and Uncle as well yeah right so a
lot of the times with how big the
families are you don't actually know who
your auntie and uncles are
like you know who your aunties and
uncles are uh and then you they'll be
they'll be someone who caught Auntie and
Uncle right and I've confirmed this with
like a few a few friends and you grow up
everything's like everything's great
everything's you know we're a nice big
happy family you grow older and then you
ask around you know like
um and and then they'll they'll be this
like they'll be
you'll talk to like one of your uncles
and then they'll they'll mention
something about a family member about
this huge drama that happens before you
were born yeah right and then you
realize oh slow like
this Auntie's not my real Auntie or that
Auntie's not my real Auntie or something
like that now he's [__] I feel like
I'm just like disrupted the core memory
right now that's so bizarre
I thought I I remember realizing I
remember thinking I had a normal family
and then As I Grew Older the more like I
I like the more dark history I uncovered
behind behind some of the [__] that
happened like with my not like not my
immediate family but like some of my
extended family yeah and then I remember
like talking to my friends about this
and I was like I had the conversation
with some of my Southeast Asian mates
and I was like yeah this is weird weird
thing I discovered with my family the
other day and they were like oh no
that's that's like five of my aunties
like the best [__]
on both sides of the family yeah let
alone on the side yeah I had my I had
one friend who was just like yeah I had
this uh I had this auntie that uh I
thought was like my blood related Auntie
for like a long time and I found out no
she's not even like blood related family
at all and then another another friend
was just like yeah uh so there's this
one cousin who I didn't realize was just
like I love child I guess just nobody
talked about it now every Asian could
just have trust issues
I would be like who do I trust dude
don't look at me dog I feel that I feel
that's very selfish
maybe that's why I [__] love all the
shitty romances I do man maybe it's just
in my blood man maybe it's in my place
that's why I'm more of an enjoyer of the
pure Ram
we got no problems with my family yeah
you know what I've grown up the order I
realized oh like all the cheesy uh soap
operas that I thought were ridiculous
maybe that's like more based on reality
than I first thought you didn't see the
small takes this is this is non-fiction
yeah yeah because I really every time
you go every it's especially like the
big family gatherings like every time
I've been to like a family wedding
there's some new piece of information
that just gets Unearthed oh yeah
I don't know we're tangent I wanted to
confirm if it was a me thing or if there
were any other Asians out there that no
one I'm talking about okay oh c Gang has
definitely got your back
[Music]
bizarre yeah how big is your how big is
your like
it's not very big family yeah not very
big yeah
um and even then like when it when it
when you do have cousins you don't
really talk to cousins I I never ever
talk to my cousins do you not do text
your cousins or anything like that yeah
all the time I don't even know
white people thing but like it's like
you don't talk to your cousins unless
it's like an awkward interaction I
[__] love my cousins yeah it's always
like in some kind of setting I feel yeah
I feel it's definitely a wide thing
because my white side uh of the family I
don't I don't know my right side I don't
even know any of them I like I I don't I
supposedly have about like 10 to 15
cousins that all live in Germany right I
ha I don't even know what they look like
I don't know their names I've never met
I feel I feel like outside of immediate
family like I feel like generally like
white people don't really care that much
unless yeah like unless they're actually
like really good friends with them yeah
I think we put way more importance on
like friends yeah I think yeah it's too
many degrees of separation yeah I think
outside of immediate family it's like no
yeah I have this weekend anywhere if
it's like if if they're family and you
know
um if they're blood related I feel like
we're all instilled with this value that
you know if they're blood related
they're like they're like a brother to
you they're like assisted you I remember
like one of one of like the weirdest
things that has happened to me is uh
where I actually like discovered
long-lost family once so yeah like I
said uh both my parents have like a very
very big family
um and uh I had I had an uncle who
unfortunately passed away before before
I was born so there was this Uncle that
I just like never knew right uh blood
related blood related okay yes yes yes
yes
I have to clarify yes
sometimes we have like secret uncles
yeah who knows it's [__] Southeast
Asian family drama
um but yeah like I uh had an uncle who I
never knew because he passed away before
I was born
um so he had a he he had a uh so my
uncle uh Michael had a kid uh with
someone from Switzerland right okay
never knew this for the longest time
right uh and by sheer coincidence right
uh we had a uh it was just me and my mum
and me and my mum and my dad and we had
a family trip to Switzerland uh and we
we were just going for like you know
we'd never been to Switzerland before we
just wanted to visit uh and my uh
my dad's uh my dad had an old phone
number of uh of my uncle of his brother
that passed away uh and he was married
to you know someone who was from
Switzerland and he had their phone
number
um so he was like you know what let's uh
I we have lost all contact with my
cousin right who is my dad's I guess my
dad's nephew right hasn't seen him since
uh since his brother passed away uh
let's try phoning this number and see
what happens uh and so we phone it and
someone picks up luckily it's
Switzerland so you know they speak
English as well
um and they said oh sorry this person
doesn't live here but the pre we could
give you the number uh we can give you
the number where the previous owner
moved to right and um and so we tried we
tried finding this new number and then
we we had gotten to like my my auntie
you know
um my you know my my uncles yeah my well
my uncles is it step odds I don't know
how how would you classify this this is
too many degrees this is a separation so
confusing now my uncle's wife basically
my uncle's wife okay
um and we've gotten through to them and
then you know my dad had an amazing
moment where we got to like he got to
reconnect with his nephew
um who he had not seen for literal
decades and uh who like my cousin didn't
even like I I think that was the first
time he'd spoken to him because he was
like he was that young when my uh when
my uh when my uncle passed away and so I
had this weird like moment where
where my dad where my dad's like uh so
we're gonna meet with your cousin now
you've never met your cousin
but uh your family
uh but like instantly like it was it was
a it was a great moment where uh I I'd
seen him for the first time and um I got
to meet him and I could instantly tell
oh oh he's blood related oh with that
thing like because he looked very very
he had like a lot of similar features to
my dad and it was just this moment where
I had just found long lost family and
I'm like that's awesome yeah I'm like
this is so [__] surreal I don't I
didn't know how to like process this and
I I literally didn't know how to process
this
um but we just like after just one
conversation I'm like
oh okay your family and instantly like
after one conversation he he I could I
could tell there was like he'd at that
time he barely spoke English right
because he was uh more speaking uh
French and German at the time he barely
spoke English but even though I was uh I
was like a teenager back then even
though we could only communicate through
like very very simple sentences I could
I could feel like I could feel like a
bond there and like after after meeting
him and after discovering that I had a
long lost cousin you know every time you
know every time uh he actually started
learning more English as well and we
kind of connected better and uh yeah it
was it was like a long lost family bond
and I'm like that's that's the good part
of that's the good part of family values
not the spicy Asian drama so that's
that's you just go to find anyone on my
family tree that I didn't exist so it's
pretty reason why they disappeared it's
like a it's like a double-edged sword
right that's that's like the good part
where you like you meet someone even if
you've never seen them before in your
life there's a family value that's
instilled in you that no matter what if
do you feel like a blood relate if if
their family you know you treat them
like family no matter what
um but then some a lot of Asian families
I feel take advantage of that as well
there are there's always like I know can
I borrow money you're family right and I
remember I remember like there's I
remember the first time I watched some
awards right and the one contingent is
this I don't know okay it it is it is I
don't know which direction but like
because found like some walls oh you
haven't seen someone that's why I'm like
what okay Summer Wars there's like two
parts of someone's there's one part
that's basically like Digimon the movie
but then there's this other part which
is basically showcasing this big
Japanese family who um who come together
for a family reunion one last time
um there's like 50 of them yeah yeah
there's like 50 of them and there's a
storyline about like the the one black
sheep of the family that nobody talks
about and I swear to God every one of my
Southeast Asian like brethrens there is
ever I don't know why they're just like
me for real there is always that one
black sheep of the family that nobody
talks about but everyone knows about it
all right except if you're a kid you're
like who is this who is who is this man
yeah and we're like
it is
but yeah that's uh yeah I do agree
though with Connor in the sense that
like I feel in a lot of like uh like
Western families it's not so much about
like cousins that you form like a really
close like almost family bond but more
like friends right yeah because in Japan
I feel the equivalent of that is
childhood friends right
okay okay
first hand I can tell you like when you
are childhood friends with someone you
like have grown up with someone ever
since like before you could even have
sentient thoughts yeah it's just you
have that connection even if it's like
five ten years since you met them yeah
the moment you get back together into a
conversation you're like yeah it's like
nothing's changed you know like you can
you could share with them anything that
you want that's so weird though because
it's like I could probably do that with
you know the cousins that I live that
that live in Germany that I'm unaware of
but it's like
it doesn't it feels more distant than
someone who has been there my entire
life right even if they're not blood
related so it's very I'm not in contact
with any of my childhood friends
I have more childhood friends than I do
because
those are your bro those are your
brothers that is my family dude my
message occasionally oh and I always hit
them up when I go back yeah I I thought
I didn't watch Summer Wars because I
thought it was gonna be about fighting
uh I mean it is in a sense it has
fighting Wars that was no yeah
it's like a digital War yeah yeah I'm
not interested just think of it's
Digimon the movie reskin that's all yeah
but I I liked that's a good movie it's
it's I the thing the thing I loved about
someone was was the family aspect
because that's that's the part that I
related with
um because yeah I had a very similar
kind of like I guess family structure
where like my grandmother was like
probably probably like probably like my
like my biggest influence in life
because she was like the fan leader and
she like was the linchpin that like kept
it on Twitter holy [__] I'm [__] I'm
[__] tearing up
holy [__] like yeah [__] I [__]
love my grandma and like she
grandma if you're watching from Heaven I
miss you I miss you Grandma
um but yeah that's that's what that's
kind of like a big reason why like I
remember Summer Wars was because like I
had a very very similar family structure
to that including all of the drama that
went with that and there's always and I
realized that now I'm that Uncle who has
the weird job because every hunger has a
good job I'm that Uncle who has the
weird job now so what is what does Uncle
dude don't worry about it don't worry
don't look it up I have an uncle that's
a YouTuber what's this that's a job yeah
that never taught me that in school